hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyys
Welt herzlich willkommen in meinem neuen
Studio ich freue mich richtig dass wir
endlich hier im neuen Studio arbeiten
dürfen und ich hier Koch und backvideos
für euch erstellen darf heute starten
wir direkt mit einem Wunsch von meinem
Team denn es gibt ja diese richtig
leckeren knusprigen vollaromatischen
Haferkekse die schwedischen Haferkekse
wir haben ja auch welche besorgt ich
glaube die berühmtesten Haferkekse aus
Schweden sind die von Ikea und die
werden wir jetzt heute
nachmachen ich freue mich da drauf weil
ich Haferkekse sehr liebe und weil ich
auch Haferflocken sehr liebe wir
probieren die jetzt auch gleich
gemeinsam ich habe jetzt mal auf die
Zutatenliste geschaut einfach ganz
normale Zutaten wie etwas Fett
Haferflocken Zucker bisschen Mehl und
werde jetzt hier mein Rezept für euch
machen und es erinnert mich auch so ein
bisschen an meine Kindheit denn meine
Schwester hat immer Haferkekse gebacken
und die hat die Haferflocken vorher
geröstet und das roch immer mega gut zu
Hause und so werden wir das jetzt auch
machen ich sage euch mal kurz die
Zutaten dafür verwende ich 200 g
Haferflocken ich habe jetzt hier die
zarten Haferflocken von Köln 125 g
weiche Butter 125 g Zucker etwas Salz
und Vanilleextrakt ein Ei 80 g Mehl ich
habe jetzt hier Dinkel Weizen geht aber
auch einen Teelöffel Backpulver und
etwas Zimt ich habe jetzt hier meine
Köln Haferflocken und vielleicht habt
ihr auch im Supermarkt im Lebensmittel
Regal auch schon entdeckt dass ich eine
Kooperation mit kölnflocken habe und ich
freue mich richtig denn kölnflocken sind
einfach die Nummer 1 Haferflocken in
Deutschland das ist die Nummer ein Marke
und es sind einfach qualitativ richtig
hochwertige Haferflocken gibt's in zart
und kernig und sie haben natürlich auch
eine große Produktpalette an anderen
Haferflocken an anderen Zerealien und
Artikeln und ich liebe sie sehr und die
begleiten mich einfach schon seit meiner
Kindheit ist einfach ein
Traditionsunternehmen und ich freue mich
dass wir jetzt ab sofort gemeinsam
Rezepte kreieren werden freue ich mich
richtig drüber jetzt legen wir direkt
mal los ich habe hier wie gesagt die
zarten Haferflocken und damit sie
schmecken wie in meiner Kindheit und das
Aroma noch intensivieren werden wir sie
jetzt kurz in der Pfanne
rösten ich gebe die jetzt hier einfach
in die wenpfanne dann bei mittelhoher
Hitze so ein bisschen rösten
Haferflocken nehme ich ja tatsächlich
wirklich jeden Tag das ist so
Bestandteil meiner täglichen Ernährung
weil sie proteinreich sind
ballaststoffreich und einfach eine gute
zutate dem Körper gut tut ich esse sie
vorwiegend sehr gesund als Porridge als
Müsli mit Skier oder eben auch manchmal
zum Backen also da sind echt eurer
Kreativität keine Grenzen gesetzt
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch Rezepte die
ihr vorschlagen wollt dann werde ich
nach und nach ganz viele tolle Rezepte
für euch kreieren aber ich habe schon
einige Ideen so jetzt einfach ein
bisschen rösten bis sie lecker
duften während die hier vor sich hin
rösten kann ich aber auch schon mal
Butter Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt
schön cremig
[Musik]
verriieren jetzt ist die eierzuckermasse
schön weißcremig und ich gebe das Ei mit
dazu einfach kurz einrühren und dann
könnt ihr die trockenen Zutaten mit den
Haferflocken vermischen und auch kurz
unterheben und ich werde euch auch
gleich das Rezept noch in Veganer
Version
[Musik]
zeigen jetzt nehme ich einfach den
mittleren Eisportionierer und setz hier
den Teig mit etwas Abstand auf ein
Backblech und dann kommt das Blech schon
direkt in den vorgeheizten Backofen und
für die vegane Version nehme ich
eigentlich fast die identischen Zutaten
statt der herkömmlichen Butter nehme ich
vegane Butter und statt dem Ei nehme ich
dann einen leinsamenei das heißt ich
nehme einen Esslöffel Leinsamen Schrote
sie und vermische sie mit drei Esslöffel
Wasser das ganze lass ich so 10 Minuten
quellen und das ist dann quasi mein
Eiersatz und dann habt ihr ganz einfach
auch vegane Haferkekse und ich finde es
nicht nur praktisch wenn man Veganer ist
sondern auch wenn man einfach mal kein
Ei zu Hause hat wenn man dann nämlich
Leinsamen hat kann man es immer als
Alternative benutzen ist immer praktisch
zu
[Musik]
wissen
und jetzt lasst se nach dem Backen auf
dem Blech abkühlen und dann probieren
wir sie
gleich
[Musik]
dann probieren wir jetzt doch mal die
Kekse ich würde sagen Tolga darf heute
probieren hello hello du bist der erste
Verkoster hier in der Küche in der neuen
Küche die ist wunderschön die ist so
schön wir fühlen uns so und mein
Arbeitsplatz ist auch schön der ist auch
richtig schön also Haferkekse ich habe
diese gekauften Kekse das sind Herr
kömmliche mit Butter und Ei und das sind
sogar vegane Kekse okay s wir einmal
überall durchprobieren ja oder so let's
go so ein bisschen mir ist auch zu
viel
crunchy süß ich mag schwedische
Haferkekse m ja und so
hier ich wollte nur ein
Stück
[Musik]
gemacht ich lieb die
das ist für mich scharfer Kekse mm das
andere ist für mich zuckerkeks ja
definitiv
aromatisch das schmeckst du das viel
intensiver finde ich ja ich habe es auch
V
ger oh lecker und einmal vegan
vegan
m auch
lecker
tatsächlich find die sogar noch besser
ja tatsächlich gibt
eigentlich zwischen den beiden kaum ein
Unterschied also geschmacklich gar nicht
Konsistenz ist bisschen weicher also der
ist so bisschen keksiger der ist
bisschen weicherau wenn man die jetzt
auch ein Tag eingepackt stehen lässt
dann werden die auch ein bisschen noch
weich in sich aber aber ich finde oh der
war jetzt echt lecker der we der ist
richtig gut vegane Kekse sind super es
ist ja quasi auch nur ein Ei drin und
das ersetzt man mit einem leinsameni und
das war's und das finde ich perfekt also
sind richtig leckere
Kekse gut ne ne und to approved richtig
lecker also schreibt mir doch mal gerne
welche Version ihr ausprobieren wollt ob
ihr die veganen Kekse ohne Ei oder die
herkömlichen Kekse zubereiten wollt und
schreibt mir auch gerne eure
rezeptwünsche für dieses Jahr ja ich
habe viele viele Rezeptideen aber
natürlich gehe ich auch immer auf eure
Wünsche ein M ich habe da auch noch was
dann kommentier es ich kommentiere es
also das Rezept gibt's wie immer auf
sellis-blog.de oder in meiner App die
könnt ihr gerne kostenlos herunterladen
da könnt ihr nämlich auch hergehen und
sagen okay das Rezept ergibt 18 Kekse
aber komm ich willür gleich die
vierfache Menge machen also haue ich die
vierfache Menge drauf die App rechnet
euch praktisch alle Rezepte hoch und
runter so wie ihr es braucht und da
stehen alle Backzeiten mit drin ihr
könnt die Temperatur Heizart und die
ofeneinstellung auch direkt an den
Backofen senden falls er eine Bosch
Backofen besitzt und so könnt ihr mit
der App wirklich wunderbar arbeiten
Einkaufslisten erstellen und so weiter
und so fort einfacher geht's nicht
einfacher geht's nicht also viel Spaß
beim nachpacken bis zum nächsten Mal und
wir teilen jetzt die Cookies mit unserem
Team
[Musik]
tschüss
tr